schäfer deutscher schiffe und ein
städtisches skates und herzlich kommen
zu einem neuen video heute mit
[Musik]
und mit meiner schwester
einige von euch nicht auf die maske
klargekommen
deswegen haben sie auch noch mal am
start ich übrigens auch nicht ich finde
das ist dermaßen leute lassen wir es
erkennen was wir heute wieder machen ich
habe eine echte wasser baum gekauft eine
echte wasserbombe das ist eine bombe die
wasser spritzt okay und was macht man
wenn mal 21 jahre alt ist studiert und
soll in seinen videos und man
wahrscheinlich ein wasserbombe oder
wassereffekte machen wir es halt einfach
so und 250 das ging so man schaltet das
an dann blinkt das und ein timer läuft
läuft und sobald der timer zu ende ist
eine zufällige zeit explodiert das ding
und wasser schießt derjenige die bombe
gerade hat wird getroffen und zwar
spielen die ganze sache so ich sag zb
großstädte in deutschland berlin geht
die bombe dann ab du darfst die bombe
dann erst weiter geben sobald du auch
eine großstadt nennt zb chemnitz und
dann ist meine schwester dann musst du
jetzt größer sein größter in deutschland
dann wird die bombe explodieren man darf
es erst weitergehen haus wichtiges
gesagt haben es beginnt immer die neue
runde bei demjenigen bei dem die bombe
zuletzt geplatzt weil dauernd jammern
bis jetzt gibt es los alter garten
laufen würde sagen ja einfach hier darum
wer die erste runde macht schere stein
papier gewinner gibt thema vor
ich bin schon mal raus
achtung was das thema pferderassen
pferderasse ist das thema und warte
jetzt braucht die druck auf und die
bombe wort druck auf und jetzt welches
die roben stelle geht es los und man
muss das ding immer so halten dass sie
auf seine gesicht zeigen hier oben so
nimmt die schuss löcher leute da oben
schießt den raus muss aufs eigene
gesicht zeigen und von den anderen weg
jetzt geht's los pferderasse
abnehmen ist keine rasse pony pony das
werk toni
[Musik]
wir sind noch tausende eingeführt ja
aber du zwölfjähriges mädchen ist damit
wohl so leicht am kopf gestritten aber
ich habe es wegen geringer ich habe fast
weggedreht habe also automatisch suchen
ich bin ja okay ich nehme minecraft
server und sommer der zinssatz ja ok
alles klar
youtube ist
pauli sowie videos gemacht ich werde
natürlich youtube drin weil es immer
noch einmal so das so ist können gehört
übrigens kostiris tage fand ja wenn du
siehst ja dann bist wer wurde jetzt
gerade ich als wert verloren haben und
noch mal genau hab ich auch direkt zu
packen dann darfst du einfach die
nächste runde es nennen okay vielleicht
diesmal keine tier fassen so ernsthaft
betroffen so kann ich heiße ärzten
rassen hunderassen hunderassen und sagen
das schiff so weit entfernt davon dran
zu sein
vogel ins auge bekommen weil gute basta
die habe ich noch gut gekauft haben sich
besser auf dem weg zu mir schon gesagt
bin ich das eigentlich dran was ich darf
das nächste thema vorgeben vortag dass
ich habe thema problem aber nicht
ja aber nie verlassen habe
nein liebe geschwister jetzt wohl dieser
runde beisammen sind und wir alle
dieselben interessen haben habe ich mir
gedacht ich jeden thema aus dass wir
alle gut kennen und deswegen autos von
der marke porsche cayenne muss
mitspielen
dessen wir doch so liste hilft vaduz ist
es soweit gehalten also ja genau ich
weiß warum wegdrücken unternehmen ist
übrigens voll seltsam leute ich will die
ganze meine schwester mit ihrem namen
nennen aber ich kann es einfach nicht
mehr den namen geheim bleiben sollte
deswegen meine schwester ich freue mich
dass ich hab so leute nächste runde
schulfächer ich beginne uns sagen
geografisch mathe englisch erdkunde so
gehalten erst war ich weiß was uns sagt
gerade in dem moment da hat das
raum-zeit-kontinuum sich gekrümmt und es
lag auf keinen fall daran dass du das
ding so gehalten dass wir alles dafür
etwas dabei sein
hier findet ihr persönlich ein
vorgeschlagenes video könne man kann
abonniert krieges in der folge was geht
und viel spaß dann nach st